so far we learned about bioinformatics
education and research training
emphasizing the role of bioinformatics
in every research lab
and the evolving role of bioinformatics
and universities and research labs in
india
now that we know about all the
opportunities around us the question
arises how do we prepare ourselves for
the research labs how do we get the
required training and enhance our skill
set not only this but also work on a
research project and get a good hands-on
before we actually hit the industry
to get all your answers let's learn
about omix logic research fellowship
program
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
worse in bioinformatics research fellows
participated in cutting-edge
bioinformatics research led by expert
mentors
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mentor guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the platform is a cloud-based analytical
server that is a t-bar for server which
uses research labs and independent
scientists around the world the data
generate the data generated by these
labs
in the omics research fellowship program
the research fellows will get a chance
to develop an independent research
project learn to utilize big data
analysis tools get guidance from
experienced mentors get an exposure
certification and feedback and get an
access to amisologic courses now these
courses are there on the portal we will
be just taking you to the portal in some
time and will showcase you all the
resources that are up there which you
can learn from and leverage the most so
these uh courseworks are on dynamics
which includes genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics data science
using our pythons specifically for
bioinformatics and machine learning and
also you will find various uh logic
project examples to understand how the
things that you learn in the course work
could be applied to answer real life
research problems or research questions
maybe and all this will be done through
t by info server which is an ai-based
web server for multi-omics big data
analysis
so now talking about our community we
leverage publicly available data online
tools for big data analysis and a
network of mentors to help students
learn bioinformatics apply their skills
to meaningful research projects and work
with mentors on turning their projects
into publications or research posters
the programs we offer provide training
access to high quality tutorials and
tools anyone can learn to use
independently the program is offered at
university high school or community
colleges levels as well as directly to
citizen scientists around the world we
have associated with industry and
academic mentors with years of expertise
in computational approaches for basic
and translational research biotechnology
and pharma companies as well as emerging
domains like space comics and
translation cancer bioinformatics
infectious diseases vaccine research
computational neuroscience air driven
chem informatics and drug discovery
now to talk about the structure of the
research fellowship program
the program is structured in such a way
that the fellows are supposed to go
through an extensive training process in
the beginning of their fellowship period
where they learn about the key concepts
of whichever specialization track they
pick it could be oncology infectious
diseases neurosciences space homicides
agriculture etc they learn about media's
data extraction analysis visualizations
algorithms involved methodologies
followed they practice it on the t bind
for server and finally propose a
research question
when they all are geared up with the
knowledge and expertise in hand
throughout this process of training and
working on independent research projects
the research fellows interact with the
mentors and armix logic community
through online zoom meetings and
communication channels like skype and
slack they help us stay in touch with
our fellows anytime they need assistance
and once the fellows have completed
their project then they can present
their work to the community in the form
of a poster presentation or a research
publication or even submit it in their
institutions to fulfill the requirement
of a minor major or dissertation project
so now let's look at some of our
research fellows projects and also learn
more about the outcomes of the research
fellowship program by one of our mentors
whose name is doctor dr dr dr weinstein
so over to dr raghav
dr raghav we can't hear you
okay just a second sir can you unmute
yourself now
uh oh justin can you make dr raghav
uh post
let me
set right now i've changed the settings
yeah can you hear me
yes sir perfect we can hear you
yeah i think yeah i think it's
i think you can hear me thank you very
much
and let's uh
let's find ways to share my screen
can you see me scream i think you can
sing this christmas we can see our
screen
thank you still not responding to me you
can see my screen yeah uh yes sir we can
see us okay thank you very much i think
i got it yeah thank you so much it's
great to be here with everybody uh
yeah so
what happened
same screen again
so
it was visible earlier but i think it's
not up here
i mean i think you need to reshare yeah
i think i need to reach out for this one
okay let me check
yes
my computer
let's try one more time
no it's not working
okay i think i got it now i think i got
my zoom just got frozen for some for
some period
sorry for the hiccup
yes
okay thank you sonalika and it's one
more time it's great to be here so today
i'm excited to share with you about how
this research fellowship program works
and how we have structured this research
leadership program so the goal of this
program is to provide training in
bioinformatics
to enable independent research which is
guided by
mentors and with
peers
to develop or to uh
develop a research project uh included
in using buying from a bio a big data
bio uh informatics
[Music]
analysis on your own project on your own
so we we actually enable students from
all backgrounds like from undergrad from
masters and from phd level and even uh
faculties uh to develop a novel and
independent research using the latest
technology and the lessons that we have
uh in learner mixed logic platform so
yeah so
this program is actually structured that
so that the students get guided through
various areas of bioinformatic data
analysis
using practical examples so during this
program we go through uh several high
quality publications and to learn about
the applications of this uh
methods and projects that these
publications describe so the kind of
this kind of hands-on experience will
allow beginners to try computational
biology techniques on public domain data
and it will also make uh everybody to
work with large files and extract
meaningful information from let's say
data that includes patient samples data
that includes animal models and cell
line models microbiota microbiome data
and etcetera etcetera so this program
actually provides support mentorship and
extensive training uh
to uh
to uh
to involve or to
implement all the skills that you have
learned from uh from the learn bio uh
learn uh omix logic platform uh to the
proposed research ideas and the topic uh
on your own so at the basis of the key
basis of this program uh is we is to
develop a project or to develop a title
of your project and the project
development for this research program
involves these seven steps so for every
project we follow this well defined
steps so you start by framing the
question and uh you start by terming the
question which is followed by extensive
literature review so once you have
identified a topic of interest then we
collect the data from publicly available
resources that will validate your
hypothesis or that will help you design
a more interesting question and explode
for possible patterns and ah from these
exploratory analysis from this
hypothesis we can actually decide on the
type of
in-depth analysis to be performed for
the data so after performing these
analysis we can
then um interpret the results in the
biological connotation or the biological
relevance for the samples and by
connecting the
big data omics and by connecting the
patterns that we find from this omix
data to the phenotypical characteristic
of the biological sample so in the end
of it all after completing
your project then you will
you are encouraged and you will be
required to submit your research project
and communicate your results to the
omixlogic platform and um you'll be uh
yes as a part of uh students project so
let's take a couple of steps from this
project development as an example and
see uh seen in in little bit uh discuss
a little bit detail how we are actually
uh trying to frame a question uh that
involves or that uh helps you to um
start your project uh
effectively so at the basis of all we
have to we have to start from a topic
that you care about or start from a
topic that interests you the most and
you can actually start with a topic that
you have some prior knowledge about and
then slowly expand to include topics
that could be of interest not only to
you but to general public or to general
audience to generalize your interest in
these topics and then you can proceed to
design or proceed to develop more
refined hypothesis or exploratory
questions for your specific project and
we also have to find uh once you have a
set of questions that you want to
explore then we have to find
the availability or the
suitability of the data that exists in
public repository that can help you
answer your question uh and identify a
perfect uh title or a specific aim for
your research project so
yeah so as you explore the topic and
make note of hypotheses and questions
on the data sets reference many
questions will come or many questions
will come to your mind and you have to
pick and choose
that is going to
that is going to fill the gap in the
literature so when you
find something really interesting uh you
have to find the suitability of that
interesting uh thought to be translated
into formal research
statement or formal research problem and
that will form your topic so
obviously collecting raw data or primary
data for your research and finding these
resources are very important so once you
have
uh and
once you have your hands on some of the
data that is available you can perform
some exploratory analysis and try to
find if the data has some pattern that
will
eventually answer your question and if
that does not then you go back to the
step again refine your question again
and try to include more data try to be
inclusive of uh
expand
your search question to include more
data and more types of data and then
thus you can refine your hypothesis
as such
so this
yeah so of course we we have a course uh
designing a bioinformatic research
project which details on how to proceed
with all the steps discussed above and
it also goes in detail about how to
start uh how start with the literature
review and go on about each and every
steps of those uh seven steps to
research project that i discussed about
so uh
uh yeah you you will yeah you are
encouraged to check this course which is
which will be extremely valuable for
budding students like
like you and
let's
wait for my
[Music]
powerpoint to respond again
is it
yes so let's take few examples of
students submitted research projects on
a variety of topics that we have already
it's
again not responding
let me
for a short while switch off my video
maybe it's getting a lot of bandwidth
i'm not able to stop my video also
if i am still audible i would pass it on
to dr mohit and come back to the come
back to a couple of slides where i am
going to discuss some um
some of the students project that is
submitted to our portal it looks like my
computer is not responding for some
reasons thank you dr raghav yeah i think
we are running out of time so thank you
for your presentation and describing the
structure of the program
and
maybe
now also we have the student
presentations coming up so request push
to
also reach out to those students who are
already here and uh get them ready
meanwhile i'll just share a little bit
about
the research fellowship program uh that
we have been discussing in this session
i hope that my screen is uh visible to
you
yes your screen is visible
now it's not i think
yeah it was uh
was not playing so i think it's fine now
so as as you learned about the omics
logic research fellowship similarly the
collaboration what we are trying to do
is that the collaboration between
industry and academia is the key
uh that has been being discussed in the
symposium and we were going to
learn from a lot of speakers were coming
from industry as well as from academia
so we believe that this collaboration
between industry and academy is the key
to catalyzing innovation and growth so
industry partnership is instrumental in
advancing research and in the creation
of skilled force work so this is
something that we are looking at as a
community uh as a company also to so to
address this uh huge uh gap between data
and the information that we have been
talking about i wanted to share how
our omixlogic community is growing with
young researchers who are contributing
by working with
experts and generating these uh amazing
resources and projects and outcomes as a
part of this experience
so i was like really very excited also i
just wanted to include that in
in this presentation that i was really
excited to check the results
from the symposium registrations form
submission so
uh the results suggested that uh 30 of
all of you
uh the participants who would like to
learn about genomics
and its application 20
of all the participants said that they
are interested in transcriptomics and
then 21
of all the students said that they are
interested in data science and
machine learning and then there was an
interest in epigenomics which is
thirteen percent and then uh
metagenomics ten percent and structured
biology person so i
i'm really happy because uh many of you
are
are inquisitive to learn more about
these
new technologies that we have been
discussing like precision medicine
president agriculture so as many of
students and faculty are already
are part of this omix logic research
community in my presentation i will
cover that how research uh university
research program uh what is this
research university program research
fellowship university program and how it
is structured so just to quickly tell
you a little bit about it so what we did
is like a collaboration with several um
several uh leaders in this area where um
they have experience of over 30 40 years
in education discussing about this uh
about the structure of how we can
we can help students and enable faculty
and uh create a pipeline to
to make the skilled workforce do
translational research to do research
which includes um these resources that
we have created for the students to
utilize so i as i was saying that
these problems that we are discussing in
our research fellowship program and
these research areas that we are
discussing is is just not related to
bioinformatics but application of
bioinformatics in different
different fields so we have
collaborators in the us africa and india
and other places
so
they are working on medical
biotechnology plant and environmental
biotechnology
uh biochemical engineering cellular and
molecular data
generation and computational biology and
bioinformatics so this enriched
community where experts are from
uh almost all the fields of biology and
uh expertise of data science and machine
learning if we incorporate that and
and with the help of industry i think
you can envision a complete uh pipeline
for students to learn all of this so
this is the pipeline that we created for
a student to go through a very basics
like basic training to um to utilizing
some of the advanced tools that we've
been discussing like ai and machine
learning and all of that and then how
this is used in terms of application
like how this uh skill sets how these
tools how these algorithms can be used
to crunch biological data and to gain
insights which are really valuable for
anyone to know so that value obviously
is going to
help you to get it may be published or
get grants and all of those things that
you learned from a previous uh speaker
so this is the pathway that we are
focused on where we have incorporated
different elements that we have prepared
and created and put together on oh miss
logic learn and team band for server so
as i was telling you that the first step
is to learn about the basics start with
the omex logic basic curriculum and
which covers the
basics of ngs and also these important
technologies where we have where we are
focused on analysis downstream analysis
and also understanding that
how can we replicate this uh while using
uh coding or a non-coding environment
so after that we learn about the
projects that are available which is to
learn about the application so you have
to
understand that how can uh actual
problem is conceptualized so many many
uh students learn about these different
techniques
but when it comes to like applying this
technique there is a huge gap also so
many students when they go to a research
lab and they they write it in their cv
that they know genomics and they know
these tools and that tools and that that
you will see many times that we get in
the cvs but uh what recruiters are more
interested is is in the application and
not only just the tools because uh in
the end you have to have that thinking
about how to solve problems that
requires a lot of um a lot of experience
working on different types of uh project
examples data sets so this is what we
are doing in step two then we have these
all different areas where student now
goes and chooses which area is what
interests the most and develop research
ideas and research projects and in this
intermediate step we have training
programs such as infectious diseases
precision oncology precision medicine
which is very much specific about these
application of these technologies which
we run throughout the year it includes
also the upcoming uh areas such as
spaceonomics
and then uh understanding the
three-dimensional data which is what we
have seen in the last uh last
presentation that how these different
areas of bioinformatics research are
combined together are like are
interconnected uh to help in the process
of
finding a solution such as drug tricks
drug discovery
and helping
for human health care so uh these
internship tracks are divided so we have
research fellowships where we uh help
students uh students and faculty to
collaborate and develop these projects
and then
once the student is capable and know how
to do this analysis they they are more
uh
they get opportunities such as industry
internships where they and they are
getting paid for uh knowing and doing
these analysis for specific pro programs
for specific groups and uh specific
research labs
so similarly like this step involves uh
integration of the faculty
which is very critical at this point of
time because
as a university ecosystem where we are
trying to enable students to work on
research projects that are defined by
faculty who are interested in
incorporating these bioinformatics tools
these bioinformatics research
utilization of the
big data utilization of the public
repositories into their research so that
they can enhance their research so that
these research have high value uh and uh
good outcomes so uh we our team
we work with the faculty to help them
develop these projects further and then
the students to work on these projects
similarly we have an initiative called
cyanomix it's a free student club where
we invite the faculty and also help the
local community or also help the
international community online community
to learn about these specific areas of
research and to learn about how research
is done through uh in different research
labs where via these
researchers faculties and um what are
the different areas that they can
contribute similar to similar to the
session that we just just we that we had
so all of this involves research
consultation where we are talking about
these different uh areas of research
working on these different areas of
research utilizing public repositories
using utilizing our online tools
utilizing the t bind for server and uh
coming up with projects and outcomes for
students helping them to get scholarship
helping them to do this on their own uh
supporting them throughout their period
of internship and then coming that that
leads to this amazing results when the
students from undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees come up with a
really noble project not only that they
get a profile and certification to
showcase to the world and also
also the
experience to work on a real research
project with real data sets so we have
several of these students who were who
were able to complete this and will be
able to present their uh their uh
results in the upcoming session so
without wasting much time i'd like to
pass it past the session to sona alika
to introduce the judges of the session
of the poster presentation where we will
have the opportunity to learn from these
students who have completed their
project completed entire analysis on
their own and have shared their
experience as well thank you so much